Okay, welcome everybody to another holistic health zoom call we have a number of questions that you submitted that will be going over so let's get to those.
Remember in the rules with the questions, you know, just because you ask a question that might not get answered if it doesn't please do submit it again.
Because I don't go back to the initial questions of three weeks ago to look at them.
So if your question didn't get answered is still still having difficulty getting help with something to submit that question again.
We're getting more and more questions and we are limited to how many that we can answer on our calls.
First question of dealing with mast cell.
So a mast cell activation this person meets everybody has mast cells in their body.
If they're hyper activated or they're over activated, then we end up with an excess about a histamine histamine production.
That's one of the things that mast cells produce is inflammatory cytokines.
So doing a good diet and using histoclear concerned about getting rid of mold and heavy metals.
I'm I'm really not sure what binders to use. I have no gallbladder.
I have auto wheeled lime issues and would like to use a rife machine.
So a rife machine is really one of the best tools for auto wheeled lime issues.
Because any other immune stimulants, if you're in, if you have any autoimmune disease, whether it be lime related thyroid brain inflammation, whatever chronic symptoms you have it if person does have really chronic symptoms that they've had for a long time.
Almost guarantee that they're in an autoimmune phase and using less immune stimulators can be better for you.
Because any time you're going to use an immune stimulator, it will activate mast cells and will produce increased cytokine so that more that you can get away from nutritional immune stimulators that better off you're going to be using a rife can be really good for that.
Or lime disease, you can run the rife or lime disease itself, or you can run the rife to help decrease inflammation. There's details, programs out there to decrease swelling decrease inflammation so they can be very beneficial.
But back up to this first part of the question, concerned about getting rid of mold and heavy metals.
If you have mast cell activation, there can be multiple and almost always is multiple reasons that we want to blame it on one thing like, oh, I have mold or oh, I have lime disease, that's why.
But it's almost always multiple things point on testing for food sensitivities can be a good idea, testing your house for mold can be a really good idea.
Testing your body for heavy metals can be a good idea, those not super accurate.
So all those things can be good. The best binder to use to me is really our clear binder to me, that's the best binder because it's the best balanced binder we have.
And you could just take a couple of days of those, it's not really, you can't overdose on binders because you're really not absorbing much of the binder anyhow.
So that's the idea it's grabbing on the things that you're got to help you calm down your gut is detoxing with the right machine easier on your body organs that using supplements.
So back to the kind of ties into the earlier question, it's, it's so it really depends on if the person have an auto immune disease.
So it's good to do them both together. So with the right machine, if you do have a right machine, the benefit of that is you have the iron pro wave, if you're talking about heavy the right machine for us.
So that's the true right that you have the iron pro wave with that, and that's a foot bath apparatus that could really help with detoxification.
So it's a really nice thing to have, it can take some pressure off your body.
And also think I think other things that could take pressure off your body, which when you're talking about having an auto immune disease, think of using the sauna, that could be very beneficial because it'll help you detox through your skin and think about doing copy animals.
But what do you really like to talk about copy animals, but they are really, really helpful because they'll really support your detox pathways, your parasympathetic nervous system and everything.
Is it possible that my diet siblings could have some of the same defect genes I have.
It's not only possible, but it's highly probable. So when you have, let's say you have, so you have alleles, right.
That's right.
I think that's why it smells.
An allele is what you're looking at. You have two alleles to each gene. So you either have a single allele defect or a double allele.
If you have a double allele defect, you got one of those from your mother and you got one of those from your father. So if you have a double allele defect, it has a two on it.
So when your gene reported has a two or a one. So that means you either have what is a single allele defect. So you could have got it from your mother or your father.
If you have a double allele defect or a two on there, that means your mother and your father have at least a single allele defect.
So that means each one of your siblings could receive that as well.
So higher chance if you have a two that your siblings would have at least a one.
If you have a two, your siblings will actually have at least a one dot all of them will have a two though.
So if your, if your father was a two and your mother was a two that every offspring will have a two.
If your mother was a one and your father was a two that every offspring will have a two. So it's kind of goes like that so you can kind of figure it out.
So some people don't do genetics other children. If they did genetics and you know both the mother and the dad, they can kind of figure out pretty good, pretty good certainty where my child is at saves a little bit of money.
As far as siblings, it's probably best to do genetic workup on each one of them. Also a caffeine gene is not highlighted.
Does this mean it's okay to drink caffeine? Yes, that's correct. So if I didn't highlight it, then you can go ahead and drink some caffeine.
Okay, so with the food genes like caffeine, genes and the genes for dairy and the genes for gluten that does not mean it's just because you don't have any genes for gluten.
So it does not mean that you don't have food sensitivities. You don't have antibodies for gluten. Same thing with caffeine.
caffeine is a food as you could actually have antibodies against caffeine. So you could have a food sensitivity to caffeine, but not have any genetic predispositions to have issues with caffeine. So they're totally completely different.
So I could have perfectly clean genes for gluten, but I have antibodies to gluten. So every time I eat gluten, I'm causing an inflammatory reaction. So don't equate genetic issues with food to food sensitivities due to antibody creation of the food particle that food peptide.
Oxalate pathway is not highlighted even though my kidney stones are oxalate based. Right. So if you don't have a lot of oxalate gene defects, that still that doesn't mean that you're still don't have the ability to get kidney stones almost all kidney stones, most kidney stones are oxalate based.
But if you have issues with your oxalate pathway, you have a much higher chance of getting kidney stones, but just because you don't have issues with your oxalate pathway doesn't mean you still wrote get kidney stones because there's other factors involved. You're going to have oxalates in your diet.
So it's how well you get rid of them. So if your genetics have play a part of how well you get rid of oxalates, but also your diet, if it's super high in oxalates, or you're dehydrated, that's a huge piece of it.
The hydrated chance you're getting kidney stones goes up as well.
Mushrooms are high in glutamates. If so, so if I take history clear when I eat them, rarely would that be okay. Yes.
And I would not worry about unless you are like a mushroom connoisseur and you eat them like gorge on mushrooms, you don't have to worry about mushrooms.
The glutamate and oxalate and histamine in mushrooms is I would be too concerned about that, especially if you're eating them rarely.
Could you tell me more about the BRCA and the MCY genes. There wasn't more information except that curcumin would help.
So there's lots of different BRCA genes and the MCY genes. These are tumor suppressor genes. So tumor suppressor genes turn on when a cancer when a cell starts rapidly replicating.
So maybe you don't have a diagnosis of cancer, but I'll guarantee you you have cancer cells in you.
Oh my gosh, is that mean I get a good cancer? No, hopefully not. Everybody's got cancer cells in you in them.
And when those cells start rapidly replicating because something damaged the DNA inside the cell, your tumor suppressor genes kick on and your body causes that cell to go through apoptosis.
Now, when you have a lot of defects in your tumor suppressor genes, your risk increases that you won't kick on a cell death process called apoptosis in that cell and that cell can continue to replicate damaged cells and end up with a diagnosis of cancer.
So with the BRCA genes and the MCY, NYC genes, the really the quote unquote fix for that or the way to deal with that is to increase curcumin because that will increase apoptosis in cells and decrease inflammation in the tissue.
So these are very common gene defects so it wouldn't be concerned about them, but it's a good idea. That's why it's really good to run your genes.
The prior to having a serious disease, you know, getting your 12 year old or eight year old genetic test done can be really helpful because then you could intervene before there's any issues and you could help ward off issues.
So good thing to do is to be ahead of the curve, you could say.
All right, that's the questions for this week. Thanks for attending. Make sure you put your questions in on the courses that you subscribe to and we'll get this up on the website and as soon as it gets processed.